13 millions d'euros le prix de la
technologie c'est ce qu'a coûté le b
hier à la sncf ce bâtiment
d'intervention rapide a été aménagé au
technicentre rive gauche le site de la
gare de triage et de maintenance à
trappes dans les yvelines a été préféré
à celui de vitry sur seine et deux
rouges en raison de sa taille
cette installation qui a mis deux ans à
être construite va permettre de traiter
une rame entière sans avoir à la
découper en morceaux gyan en séparant
les voitures donc ça nous permet de
gagner du temps en termes de maintenance
donc c'est un peu comme un instant de
formule 1 si je voulais faire une
comparaison on va très vite pour changer
les roues l'objectif de ce bâtiment est
de réparer et entretenir le matériel et
notamment changer les roues en un temps
record moins de une heure pour changer
ses essieux de près d'une tonne une
installation qui facilite également le
travail des équipes 178 salariés oeuvre
sur ce site
c'est un réel avancement en termes de
qualité au travail et notamment pour la
santé et la sécurité au travail des
agents
puisque ça diminue fortement les
opérations de maintenance délicate
c'est à dire les coupes de caisse
l'élevage
donc on est complètement assisté
entièrement mécanisée et donc ça réduit
fortement la pénibilité au travail en
fonction depuis le 10 février le
bâtiment intervention rapide peut
traiter une vingtaine de trains par
semaine un moyen d'impacter positivement
les conditions de circulation pour les
usagers assurer des interventions plus
rapides comme sur la clim aussi sur le
chauffage est donc là également on parle
du confort clients le beyer traitera
également les rames du transilien des
lignes n et u et ceux de la ligne
paris-le mans en tout ce sont deux cent
quarante trois rames qui pourront être
prises en charge à trappes